como miles de profesionales
latinoamericanos del campo sanitario
daniel y pierina se han confrontado
desde su llegada al continente europeo a
una dura realidad el no poder trabajar
como médicos desde que se fueron de
venezuela desde que llegué a europa no
he podido ejercer mi profesión ha sido
pues muy complicado el proceso de es un
proceso que en todos los países es una
burocracia enorme originarios de maracay
al oeste de caracas esta pareja de
médicos cirujanos ha logrado beneficiar
de una medida aprobada por el parlamento
italiano una autorización temporal para
que los extranjeros profesionales de la
salud trabajen en italia durante la
crisis pandémica la esperaría que este
sea el inicio de muchas oportunidades
como médico a la puerta de entrada una
ilusión que comparten los otros miembros
del grupo de médicos venezolanos
seleccionados para trabajar en los
hospitales de la región molist en el sur
de italia una iniciativa apoyada por el
vicepresidente del senado italiano quien
considera la presencia de estos
profesionales
indispensable en este momento para
italia de un country wood es una
contribución importante aquí hay tanta
necesidad de médicos enfermeros y
personal en salud entonces cualquier
ayuda es bienvenida y para ellos es una
buena ocasión canciones de crédito a
partir de este momento pasan a ser
empleados del sistema regional de salud
y inicialmente el contrato es por un mes
van a ser contratados con exactamente
las mismas condiciones económicas de un
médico italiano esta mañana los 18
médicos venezolanos contratados llegan
con sus maletas listas al centro de roma
entre ellos hay cardiólogos neumólogos
cirujanos y médicos generalistas todos
guiados por una misma motivación podemos
demostrar lo que somos como
profesionales y dar lo mejor de nosotros
es una oportunidad de compartir
unir fuerzas entre médicos ayudar a que
la gente viva entonces pienso que van a
sentirse bastante agradecidos y nosotros
también agradecidos de poder trabajar
juntos llegó la hora de partir inicia
para ellos un viaje de la esperanza la
esperanza de lograr construir un futuro
estable en la península italiana